-Our next guest won
a Golden Globe
for his portrayal of
Prince Charles on "The Crown".
The fourth season is streaming
on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-What can you tell us abou
the actual wedding?
-We're not that far on yet
but for now,
w-w-we're delighted, really.
-Mm-hmmm.
-Well, I see you're going to
bring a deep and lasting joy
to the nation,
and if I may say,
you both look very much in love.
-Oh, yes.
Absolutely.
-Whatever in love means.
-Please welcome to the show,
Josh O'Connor.
How are you, Josh?
-Hey, I'm good.
How are you?
-I'm doing very well.
I mean, we obviously see fro
that clip
and anybody who's watched
the show,
of which many have, this i
a very buttoned-up family,
needless to say.
But when Gillian Anderson
was here,
she showed us some
off-camera video.
And it does seem like you're
actually a pretty fun,
happy lot.
-Yeah. I mean, we're kind of -
It's bizarre.
We're sort of, like, you know,
we're obviously playing
these very buttoned-up
characters
and that video is incredibly
embarrassing, obviously.
But also, it sort of shows how
we all were, you know.
Whenever we're together, we're
sort of, um...
Usually when the whole cas
comes together on
"The Crown", it's for a jubile
or a wedding
or something --
some grand occasion,
so we're dressed up quite smart,
and then -- but its carnage.
I mean, it's complete carnage.
you've got Olivia Colman,
who's like, "Up for a dance?
Gillian and Tobias,
we're all kind of, you know.
-I think it was very nice
for all of us to see
Margaret Thatcher dancing to
Lizzo.
Which was, obviously, histor
didn't allow that until...
-We've all been waiting fo
that.
-You, um -- From that clip, we
also see what a nice job you did
nailing the Prince Charles
voice.
Was that -- Did you know muc
about him going into this?
-Do you know what? Actually,
I mean, I really didn't.
I feel like -- it's kind of --
I guess I was sort of
a republican.
I mean, I'm sort -- I gues
my family and I,
it wasn't something that was
like, very important
to us growing up, and wasn't
something we kind of
kept a close eye on.
In the U.K., there was, like
kind of --
there was this spitting imag
version of Prince Charles,
the comedy of, like,
the kind of sort of
comedic version of this -- like,
caricature of this guy.
And so that was my sort of
perception of him.
And it was only when I met u
with the guys,
Peter Morgan, he writes
the show,
and Ben Caron, the exec producer
and director
that I sort of -- when I started
speaking to them,
I realized it was someone --
it was kind of an incredibly
complex character.
Someone who was dealing with
huge philosophical questions
like, you know, waiting fo
his mother to die,
for his life to take meaning
Suddenly, it was like, "Oh, he's
not just a kind of prince.
This is a kind of -- this is
Shakespearean in its quality
So yeah, I got really excite
once I spoke to them.
In terms of my experience with
the Royal Family, I'm the wors
person to talk about
the Royals.
I have no idea about anything to
do with the Royal Family.
-But I think that must be one of
the most fascinating
things about anyone who is
making this show right now
about a family that is obviously
still around,
and I have to imagine,
especially when you're doing
press for the show, how ofte
people ask you your take
on the current things that are
happening with the Royal Family,
be they new babies
or, you know, big interviews
Do you just constantly let
people down by having
no interest or awareness?
-Oh, completely.
I mean, I remember going to --
We went to the Golden Globes
pre-lockdown, pre-pandemic
Went to the Golden Globes an
I was kind of -- I was wide-eyed
in sort of -- in amazement o
the whole thing.
It was the first time I'd been
to a major awards ceremony
And I remember going and we were
doing the press line,
Helena Bonham Carter, myself
and Erin Doherty,
who plays Princess Anne,
and we were going through
and every journalist
was asking us about Harry an
Meghan at the time.
They always ask us about Harry
and Meghan,
but this was about Harry
and it came to me,
and I honestly was --
I felt such embarrassment at
knowing honestly nothing.
I mean, really, it did tak
a moment to go,
"Who is Harry and Meghan?"
And then I realized who it was
I was like,
"I'm the worst person."
So I sort of -- there couldn't
be a kind of less qualifie
spokesperson for
the Royal Family than me.
-But it must make it nicer, to
some degree, to not have
that baggage when you play
a part,
because then you can play it
like a character
as opposed to, you know, havin
some -- the haunting image o
the real person sort of
lurking over you.
-Yeah. Oh, for sure.
I think this is something that
I'm sort of --
I've talked about a lot.
I always think that I've never
played a real person before.
But I remember when I was coming
to this,
there was a big kind of --
you know, because we'd had
season 1 and 2, and Claire Foy
and Matt Smith,
who are unbelievable in playin
the Queen and Phillip,
I've had this huge pressure to
replicate
the real Prince Charles.
And so did I lots of work on
the voice and lots of work
on the way he stands and
the way his back is arched
and all these things.
And actually, it took seeing a
Todd Haynes film --
the Todd Haynes film
about Bob Dylan --
to make me realize that
actually, you don't need t
play the real person at all.
And that film,
if anyone's seen it --
I don't know if you've seen it
but it's beautiful.
-Yes, it's fantastic.
-8 actors playing, like,
not just Dylan
but, like aspects of
his personality.
It's like, Heath Ledger play
the sort of, like,
rock star version,
and Cate Blanchett plays
the most kind of recognizabl
version of Dylan.
What I loved about it is rathe
than going, "Let's try and
imitate the real Dylan, becaus
none of us know who he is,
let's try and grapple with
the poetry
and the essence of someone."
And so, for me, it was reall
liberating knowing
that I don't know anything
about Charles,
so I could never
do a good version of him.
But also, I'm not a mimic.
And, that was -- Yeah,
I found that really liberating
just going, "I'm just going to
play him for who he is."
For the kind of the essence of
him rather than the real person.
-Well, the approach paid off
It's really a wonderful
portrayal,
and thanks so much for
being here.
I'm a big fan,
and hopefully next time,
you can be here in person.
-Yeah, I hope so.
Thanks so much for having me
-Of course.
The fourth season of "The Crown"
is streaming on Netflix.